europa está bajo alerta sanitaria debido
a las altas temperaturas que azotan el
continente las personas especialmente de
mayor edad o con enfermedades de base y
las infraestructuras podrían tener
dificultades para soportar el calor así
que tenemos que intentar mantener
nuestros cuerpos frescos porque de lo
contrario se sobrecalientan por dentro y
entonces las cosas empiezan a ir mal con
nuestra presión sanguínea y finalmente
con nuestro corazón y otros órganos
internos las olas de calor también
pueden empeorar las enfermedades
existentes como las cardiovasculares
diabetes o problemas en el riñón en
casos más extremos provocar la muerte
-la o ms prevé que a partir del 2030
unas 250 mil personas podrían morir al
año como consecuencia de la crisis
climática
38 mil de ellas por olas de calor
cabe señalar que la alta temperatura no
es la única consecuencia adversa de las
olas de calor la atmósfera estable y
estancada actúa como una tapa para
atrapar los contaminantes atmosféricos
incluidas las partículas aumentando su
concentración más cerca de la superficie
esto da como resultado acción de la
calidad del aire y efectos adversos para
la salud particularmente para las
personas vulnerables fútbol tipo según
los científicos las olas de calor son
cada vez más frecuentes e intensas
debido al cambio climático la península
ibérica' se enfrenta ahora a las
condiciones más secas desde hace más de
mil años durante los primeros días de
julio portugal reportó al menos 238
muertes relacionadas con las altas
temperaturas y españa- 84 por la
sofocante ola de calor